you describe that in the book and I
think you're onto something there for
sure and I think it's a very honest
admission that when you're on television
or you're you star in a movie like I had
that experience it's like a cocoon it's
like you're back in the under womb they
cater to your needs you're you're almost
infantile and suddenly everyone is
surrounding you say the guy in the
walkie talkies like she's moving she's
most like everyone is paying and you
love it love it this is what you've been
craving your whole life
it's like wow someone is finally taking
care of me I was finally being parented
so the psychological picture I'm getting
you're saying look I was raised in an
environment where I wasn't cared for my
father abandoned me my mother didn't
take care of me I got famous and for the
first time in my life I felt fully like
I had arrived like it like I had arrived
and that I was cared for but that kind
of love is not real is it two people on
the set while they might admire you it's
not real affection and love exists
searching that out was probably a very
empty feeling well no it's not because
it is love with those people you work
with them every day and you become they
become family so I would argue that the
the real accolade that you're looking
for which is the public accolade isn't
real the personal relationships you have
are real like I don't want to diminish
those because those were wonderful years
they were so much fun yes but would you
treat the people who are taking care of
you on set maybe sometimes as a child if
you couldn't get what you want that you
would take it out on them um no I didn't
act like that I mean I would you know I
can end up turning them into parents ya
know I didn't act like that with the
people that were working on the set you
know maybe with my assistants I've been
like oh you know like temper or been
short-fused and and said I have been
absolutely because you're not reading
your mom I can't I get this why wasn't
this here why isn't that there but you
know that it was part of my growth like
that was like I had to address all of
that I had to go why do I have no
[ __ ] patience why can't I do anything
for myself why am I do I have domestic
amnesia I hooked up a TiVo once in the
early 2000s I know I did one right and
and you know with I know you're a big
meditator but you know I had to quiet I
had to sit and quiet and not talk to
anybody and literally like hunker down
with my therapist and me to dig out all
of the things that I've been stuffing in
you know stuffing in my pocket for four
years